let's take one more call if we have it
617 830 4750 this will be the last call
from today I hope it's good we don't
know ahead of time who's on the phone
and where you calling from a David
Addison mr. regular again Mitch from
Vancouver great what's going on hey I
was wondering uh it's a corporate media
outlet offered you position doing like
whatever you want to doing yeah i would
take position and what factors would go
into your decision making well listen
this is a sort of pie in the sky
question that i've been asked before and
i tend to answer the same way which is I
don't know that what you're suggesting
really exists because everybody I know
all of my friends and acquaintances and
colleagues who either currently or
formerly worked in corporate media they
often stated that they were sort of
convinced they they agreed to believe
that hey it's not independent media but
you can do whatever you want and it was
just never true right i mean we heard
from Genk you go from The Young Turks he
famously told us his story on MSNBC and
more rather than host its commentators
that I know Mike Papantonio just last
week in Las Vegas was telling me
situations where he was invited as a
guest and told hey yo you do what you do
your thing PAP you do whatever you want
and then he would say something about
you know our case he had that implicated
a particular corporation or whatever
else and it would be black out for a
year or more on some media outlets so
you know if the question is in a
completely unrealistic scenario where
you were guaranteed total independence
and a bigger platform who wouldn't
accept that right but Rachel I just
don't think it's realistic yeah I mean I
don't know I feel like some people could
argue oh but what about Jon Stewart or
people like that who seemingly say
exactly what they want but again it's
kind of like you can't really have that
foresight no it's it's hard to believe
that in spite of everything everyone
tells me about the fact that no matter
what your promise there is someone else
with whom the buck stops on what you are
and aren't allowed to say that all of a
sudden I would be offered that but of
course as a sort of rational person uh
Mitch I would i would entertain any
offer where my audience would grow
without restricting editorial control it
does that make sense yeah that's a great
answer go all right always great to hear
from Vancouver thank you so much for the
call we are going to move on a lot more
show today thanks to everybody who
called I feel like today was a I would
chalk it up as a very solid day of calls
wouldn't you agreed yep all right we
will take a break back with plenty more
after this